[MUSIC]
[BLANK AUDIO] Hello and
welcome to our webinar with the BBSA.
My name is Famatta Mansa and
I'm a second year here at the GSB, and
I'm joined by two of our incoming
presidents of the BBSA, as well.
I'm joined by Elise and Ruth.
Like me,
they're also current students, and
as I mentioned their incoming
presidents for the BBSA.
We'll be talking about our
personal journey to the GSB,
some of our career decisions, and
then life after the GSB for me, and
answer as many questions
as we can during this time.
To submit a question all you have
to do is click the Q&A button
at the bottom of your screen.
We won't be talking about the admissions
process or financial aid.
If you do have those questions we
encourage you to reach out to admissions
and to financial aid to get those
specific questions answered.
Let's begin with introductions.
Elise and Ruth, can you please start by
telling us a little bit about yourselves.
Where you're from, what you'll be doing,
what you were doing before you came
to the GSB, and
what you'll be doing after graduation.
Elise, let's start with you.
>> Great, thanks, Famatta.
Hi, everyone, I'm Elise Smith.
I am originally from Chicago.
As Famatta mentioned, I am an MBA1.
I'm also a joint degree student in
pursuing a Masters in education.
Prior to getting to Stanford I was at
IBM Watson where I was developing early
iterations of Watson for
education products, and
leading ed tech partnerships.
And more recently was at New Schools
Venture Fund, a philanthropic fund that
invests in the education space working
in their Diverse Leaders portfolio.
>> Great, thank you.
Ruth,how about yourself?
>> Hi everybody, my name is Ruth,
originally from Nigeria,
I'm an MBA1 incoming
president like Famatta said.
I started my career at Ernst & Young where
I audited several entertainment, and
healthcare, and
real estate companies in Los Angeles.
But have also spent a significant portion
of my career working in different
capacities on the African continent,
particularly in Kenya and
Nigeria in fintech companies.
So I'm super excited to be here and
to answer you guys' questions.
>> Great, thank you guys.
Let's get started with some
questions submitted by the audience.
Well, this one's a pretty easy one.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Why did you come to Stanford, and
what did you come to learn?
>> Do you want to start?
>> Sure, so why did I come to Stanford?
I came to Stanford because I got in,
number 1.
>> [LAUGH].
>> But I'd always known that I wanted
to get my MBA, because I knew I wanted
to pivot my career from more finance
focused to more tech focused.
Like I said in my introductions,
I am from Nigeria.
And so one of my life goals is to help
bring African-owned products
to the rest of the world.
And I felt that Stanford was
the best place for that.
Not just in terms of getting your MBA,
like you can at other schools, but
really a hub for creativity like I've
never seen before in any other MBA campus.
And then what was the second question?
>> What did you come to learn?
I think you-
>> Yeah,
that's exactly what I came to learn.
And to just meet amazing people
from all over the world,
which has definitely been
a check off the check list.
>> Yeah, similarly coming to Stanford for
me was because it offered something
that no other school did.
And so the first, it's the Masters in
education joint degree program with
the MBA, you can do it in two years, and
which is a really positive experience and
part of why I came.
But also I knew I was interested
in social entrepreneurship.
I knew that I wanted to be in
an area where ed reform and
social justice were part of kind
of the fabric of the environment.
And I think that, paired with kind
of the entrepreneurial spirit,
the VC spirit here in the Bay was
something that I couldn't turn down.
>> Yeah, I think I definitely
resonate with you guys
on just the global experience.
For me it also was a lot
of the soft skills,
the ability to hone in and
invest in myself.
So I think that's also a really unique
thing that Stanford does bring,
whether that's through
interpersonal dynamics,
also known as touchy-feely, whether
that's coaching and developing others and
some of our peers, I think those
are two important things, as well.
What made you, I assume Ruth,
you're a pretty successful person,
that you got into some other schools,
as well, and same as you, Elise.
I think you guys talked about it a little
bit, but can we really double down on why
did you choose Stanford, potentially over
other opportunities that you may have had?
>> Yeah, I think it would double
touch on what you mentioned, Famatta,
and that I think the Stanford program
really focuses on becoming a leader that
others want to follow, that helps you take
time to think about what that means for
your leadership style, and
then gives you a bunch of opportunities
to practice that and live through that.
And so whether it's giving a low keynote
where you get to think about what's
a point of view or
perspective you want to share, and
then getting to give a Ted-like
talk to the community,
I took advantage of that opportunity
this year, that was really powerful.
Whether it's taking touchy-feely, getting
to be a coach and a mentor for other
students, or going through leadership
labs where that's your first quarter,
you're working with a team and kind of
a squad, is what they call them, and
getting to get feedback about how you come
off, giving feedback to kind of your peers
in this really exciting kind
of collaborative environment.
I didn't see that in other programs
as much as an emphasis, and
that was something that was important for
me knowing that I'd want to lead
my own venture in the future.
>> I think for me,
funny enough, I chose Stanford because
I was out of my comfort zone here.
I'm used to, I used to do audits, so the
process, everything is really laid out for
you and it's up to you to really
follow through on the rules.
And I really felt like said here your
experience is really what you make it
because administration really wants to
see people do as many different types of
things as possible.
And I think at other schools, number 1, it
might be easy to get lost in the numbers
and then you're just kind of following
the process that's laid out for you,
but here it's really about, yes you can do
things like lead labs and low keynotes.
But you can also be fully working on your
company and getting funded for that and
be one of many students getting funded for
really amazing things that,
like they're doing, I know Elise is one
of those students getting funded for
an amazing company.
So for me knowing that the school also
focused more on the individual and
less on clusters, really spoke
a lot to me, because I felt like
I might experience would be different
then all the other 400 students.
And I really felt strongly
that I would get that year,
also you can't beat California's weather.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And so,
all of those things are the reason
why I chose Stanford.
>> Yeah, I think Stanford has so
many niche opportunities, too.
I think for us, there's so many students
doing different things, from some of
my classmates who are bee keepers and
working in agricultural, there's just so
many things that people are doing, and
especially things I never knew before.
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Everyone is kind of doing their own
thing, but able to utilize the resources
to their advantage, as you guys talked
about, and as you definitely do now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Working on your own amazing venture,
and I think that's really
unique about Stanford,
is you have all the resources of the
broader university, while still being able
to be part of this organization and
move forward with everyone else.
So speaking of,
from your guys' perspective what
is the Stanford community like?
If someone were to ask you,
what makes Stanford Stanford?
Talk about kind of the cultural
element and what you've experienced.
Yeah, I think I would say one of
the things I love is this focus on kind of
vulnerability and being open and
being your authentic self.
It's something that I think is really
highlighted in the program Talk where
students get to talk about,
45 minutes to share what ever they want.
Often times its personal
stories about their lives or
things that they have
thought about deeply.
And the whole community comes out and
BA ones and BA two's, and I think that,
people are just standing giving
an ovation for ] I don't know,
like five minutes it seems sometimes.
And I think that to me is such a hallmark
of the community, and I think it comes
out then in other places in just
one-on-one conversations and coffee chats.
Someone got a coffee chat
with me the other day,
we were talking about media and new media.
But we didn't get there until
like the last 15 minutes.
And for the first 30 minutes,
it was just us learning about each other
getting to know what drives us talking
about having a partner at the GSB.
And so I think that to me, the piece where
it's like you're not necessarily this
business person where you're like, I'm
going to get a coffee chat to learn about
finance, and
I'm going to only talk about that.
It's like we're people first and
I think that's something that's
really beautiful about the community.
>> Yeah.
Something that I love about Stanford
community is actually just the layout
of the community.
So for those who haven't visited
Stanford yet, we have classes, really,
on one side of the street, and residential
areas on the other side of the street.
So it takes all of two minutes to
get from your doorstep to class.
And it's not even just about
the distance it takes to get to class,
it's more about the community
that you have as a first year
where you're not driving extremely
far to see your classmates.
Or if you're going through something,
whether it's a homework assignment or
something at home,
either your roommates or
400 friends are there with you,
within a really small radius.
So over 95% of, I would say,
first years live in these residences.
They're pretty nice.
It does feel like a golf resort a lot of
the days, but I also think that it helps
to create a real, true sense of community
because you're not worried about distance.
We do, so many events in the residences,
from birthdays to bridle
showers to you name it.
We just hangout together.
We also definitely have
time to go to the city, but
I think that that part really just creates
a natural space for people to get to know
each other outside of what might be
a natural click in another area.
So, for example, none of my friend
groups are a status quo group and
I really like that and I think that
the residences really help to create that.
Yeah, but
even if you don't live in the residences,
[LAUGH] you still you can still
be a part of the community.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, true, true, true.
>> Very true.
>> Yeah, yeah, great.
We have some more questions.
So I think this is a great one for us.
So getting a little bit into more
of the pre application process.
Have any of you been involved in MLT or
other programs.
These school applications.
And we're laughing because
[LAUGH] MLT was what I did.
Ruth, I know you did it.
>> I did it, yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
why don't we take a second
to talk about that.
>> Yeah, for me personally,
MLT was a life changer.
Coming from LA I didn't really
have a circle of people that were
like minded and ambitious as I was.
And I think the vibe that MLT
provides you with just like amazing
people of color from all over the country.
I think almost 300 were in our cohort
who are as ambitious as you are.
That really helped me in terms of
this whole application process.
I also wasa weird case where
I did MLT from Africa.
So it was still relatively easy for
me to keep
in contact with my coach
as well as my MLT cohort.
So in terms of MLT really being just like
you feel like you're being in the trenches
together with other people,
you getting recommendations together,
you're reading each other's essays.
I know one of my classmates helped
me read my essay for Stanford.
We read each other's essay and
we both got in.
So MLT was really amazing.
I know there are other programs like For
Women and things like that, but
those things really helped me feel like
I had a community even before I got to
Stanford and
I still have that community today.
>> Yeah.
I think for me MLT was really helpful and
valuable, but I think because
I wasn't confident that I wanted to go to
business school and it was still something
I was weighing, I think I maybe got
a little bit less out of the program.
I also I wasn't necessarily interested
in going to just any business school,
and I think for
me I really had my heart set on Stanford.
And so I think, although it was really
helpful to go through that kind of program
and explore a bunch of different programs,
I think for me I knew I wanted to
come here, and I wasn't sure if
business school was the right thing.
Camp was coming most recently from
the social sector and so you think it was
a great network and a great experience but
I think without it it also is possible
to apply and get to school and
make a network in community here as well.
>> Yeah.
So to clarify what MLT is-
>> [LAUGH]
>> We should do that first.
It is management leadership for tomorrow.
It's essentially a program that's
geared at filling the pipeline
from the C suite,
all the way down to entry into college.
And this specific program is the MBA prep.
So that's one of the lines,
the pipelines in there.
So what MLT specifically does
is geared at African Americans,
Hispanics, and Native Americans, again,
to fill the pipeline of traditionally
underrepresented minorities in the space.
And so it's just a coaching program.
You have a cohort as Ruth mentioned.
It's really just a support system for
about a year before
business school starts.
So really understanding the process,
knowing what it takes to get in,
knowing what your profile needs to be,
and you get coaching, and so
it's, essentially, a great program,
and highly recommended.
Feel free to look it up.
I also did MLT, and for me, I think,
similar to Ruth, what she mentioned,
is my cohort was very instrumental
in even me coming to Stanford.
I already knew a ton of people who had
gotten in round one, I applied round two.
So it was great just having people who
I knew look like me, who I had met,
who look extraordinary people but also
people that I've shared a drink with or
gone to lunch with, actually having
someone that I knew went to Stanford.
I think prior to MLT, I didn't know
any anybody that went to Stanford.
So it just made it still aspirational, but
an achievable concept for me.
Let's take on applications.
I love this question.
Were you ever scared at any
point in time of applying?
And is the school just full of nerds?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Question, definitely not.
>> I don't think I'm a nerd,
I don't know about you guys.
>> I mean, is being a nerd a bad thing?
>> I aspire to be a nerd.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It is Nerd Nation, so-
>> Nerd Nation, you want to-
>> Yeah, sure,
I think scared is an interesting word.
I think for me,
it always felt like you couldn't
guarantee you were going to get in.
>> M-hm.
And I think that's true for
every business school.
And I think perhaps especially true for
[LAUGH] Stanford.
And so I think for me it was always,
one, is business school right for
me, especially where I'm at now in my
journey, is this the best step to take?
And then, two,
it's such a time investment to apply.
Almost it felt like a different
job outside of my regular job.
And had to get support from mentors and
advisers, and
it was like, I'm going to go through this.
I want to make sure I'm putting
my time in the right place.
And so I think it was scary in that sense.
It was scary to Invest so much time into
something that didn't feel for sure.
And then also I wasn't sure, and so
a lot of those uncertainties were at play.
Are we all nerds?
I don't know how to answer that.
[LAUGH] I hopefully would
aspire to be a nerd.
I enjoy the classes a lot and love
learning, and if that makes me a nerd,
then I guess there I am.
>> Yeah.
>> For me, I wasn't scared because
I really was applying to
Stanford blind in a lot of ways.
Similar to Femetta I didn't really
know people that went to Stanford.
I knew one person that went to
Stanford before I got in and
I know that there people who might have
known dozens of people just based on
people that worked with them.
Or friends or family members and
things like that.
So I don't even think I knew enough to
be scared, to be honest with you guys.
But I think that I really just applied
on my best foot, and I think we
might get into some questions about when
is it right to apply and things like that.
But I applied knowing that this
is the best I have to offer, and
thankfully it was good enough.
So super, super happy about that.
In terms of being a nerd here,
are we all nerds?
I actually think what I have noticed
at Stanford is that people really
aspire to improve
themselves intellectually.
And that has become currency one of the
different currencies and I actually don't
think that that's a bad thing because in
terms of having fun like fun is in you.
So if you can have fun and you're not
a nerd that could be possible, too.
So I don't think that,
I think that being a nerd might be
actually a good thing, personally.
But that doesn't take away from
having an amazingly fun and
amazingly great experience.
So, that's how I see it.
[LAUGH].
>> Yeah, I think that's well said.
I think exactly what you said,
people here have done amazing things,
are inspiring to do amazing things.
I consider people aspirational but
that also sometimes is correlated with
wanting to read a book and [LAUGH].
But equally we have a lot
of fun I think if you want
to be social there is
something every single day.
I think I've gotten myself
caught into that sometimes.
>> Yeah.
>> Sometimes I have to just fall back and
read a book and watch some Netflix on
the weekend just to calm down, but
I think the school is, you'll find
over 400 students in one grade.
So once you kind of combine all
the programs, you have over 800 people.
Just naturally 800 people,
you're going to have a range-
>> Yeah.
>> Of what people do want to do and
what they don't want to do.
So I actually consider even the diversity
in people's experiences and
what they want to do.
And even on the nerd scale
I say there's a diversity.
>> Yeah, for
those that do want to come and nerd out.
There's definitely opportunities.
>> Yeah.
>> To do that.
You can be super focused on academics.
You could nerd out in terms of one of my
favorite groups is a political group.
Where you come together and
discuss politics once a month.
This past month was super heated.
Some months it's a little more chill.
But that thing,
that's a community that I consider we all
nerd out on different facts like that.
>> Yeah.
>> So different ways to be nerd and
different ways to engage in the community.
>> This might be a good time to ask or
to tell people kind of yours
your favorite activities I think
you mentioned that or clubs.
I can start one of my favorite
clubs is the wine club.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just because it's so
amazing we have Somalias
speaking a little bit of nerdy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But in the wine sense.
They come, they do tastings.
We talk about the notes, and
the tenants and all that.
And we've had, especially with
NAPA Valley being right up the road,
we've had special guests come and
special wineries come.
>> Yeah.
>> And teach us and
be a little bit more
educated in the wine space.
So that's one of my favorites.
>> There I like so many favorites.
>> Yeah.
>> This is really hard.
>> Pick two.
Pick one or two.
>> I'm sure we'll talk
about the BBS later.
>> Yeah.
>> So we can put that aside.
>> Yeah, for now [LAUGH]
>> I love the social entrepreneurship
community.
So social innovation, there's a club.
There's the Center for Social Innovation.
There's just like a ton of pieces and
ways to plug into that community.
And they've not only been super helpful
and starting something on my own, but also
in just providing support and guidance and
just folks to talk about different things.
And so social entrepreneurship
kind of runs the gamut and
social innovation runs the gamut.
But getting to learn from other MBA
students experience has been super
valuable to me,
as well as the advisers and
the mentors and venture studio you can
go work on your idea there at least.
>> Yeah.
>> I should stop talking because I could
go on forever [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think one of my favorite activities
here is travelling [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I'm going to go there.
>> Yeah
>> [LAUGH]
>> So and the funny thing is at the GSV
travelling can mean a ton of things.
So it can mean going to yellow stone and
spending a weekend hiking and working and
with people that you gotten to know.
Or it can be getting an academic
experience in another country,
which we call GSC's here.
Or it can be going to Indonesia and
making your own cultural and
academic experience or doing that in Cuba.
So I love how just very
textured our traveling
experiences are here, you can have
a great time where you do nothing or
you have a lot of alcohol or you can
have a really great learning experience.
And it's not just because
the school mandates it,
it's because people have
this drive to really
immerse themselves in different
cultures and in different experiences.
And humbly get to know those cultures and
experiences.
So in terms of me,
all the places I've been to with my
Stanford whether friends or classmates,
for the purposes of school or for
the purpose of just like us planning
a trip, I've had just amazing time.
And even in the times that are not
specifically learning experiences,
I've still learned something because I got
to know my classmates a little bit better
because we were in
the middle of Cuba together.
Or I got to know what business
is like in Brazil and
what the future of tech in Brazil is
going to look like in the next 10 years.
>> Yeah, and I think the point about
the international component to,
>> Yeah.
>> We do have a big international
presence here at Stanford.
And so that also helps to, you get to
go to your classmates home country.
>> Yes.
>> In Mexico.
>> Kazakhstan.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah and so Mexico and
then even some South Korea,
>> Lebanon.
>> Israel, just all over.
>> Yeah, all over South Africa.
>> Zimbabwe.
>> Yeah, so
that's also a really cool experience too.
There doesn't have to be an official
school sponsored event but
through your classmates you can still
get that experience and exposure.
And those have been some of the best
experiences here at Stanford for me.
So another question is, Stanford
has an exceptionally diverse class.
Look at that transition.
How is it being a person of color at
the TSB considering the environment of
other top schools and low percentages
in the minority communities.
>> For me, I would say that being
a minority here, in terms of me
having the identity of being African but
also considering myself black American.
I think that it is different
from other schools
that have much larger classes,
just because of numbers.
So if you have a 400 student class, versus
a 900 student class, obviously there would
be more, or hopefully [LAUGH] I would say,
there would be more people of color.
>> From a numbers perspective.
But what I love about this
community is that because we
are smaller we have so many more
opportunities to get to know each other.
And in a lot of ways we feel like
we're in the trenches together
in terms of continuing to create more
access for those coming after us.
I will say that it makes you feel like you
are more of an agent of change rather
than more of a cog in the process.
I don't know if that's the right
phrase and I also love the fact that,
In terms of, I'll speak within
the black community, there's so
many different experiences
within that community.
I've never met a diverse group of black
people like I've met at Stanford.
And I love that.
Because I get to see what life is
like if you are from the Midwest or
what life is like if you're from
the Upper East Side of New York, or
Johannesburg, South Africa.
And people get to understand
what my life was like, too.
So I love that.
In terms of now looking outward for
the rest of our classmates,
I will say that I've also never met
a more set of intrigued people who
genuinely want to know what my
experience is as a black woman.
And who want to come into that
with humility as well as just
a sense of wanting to learn
what my life is like,
and hopefully wanting to
connect with me in that way.
And so that's also something that I've
seen in a lot of my classmates and
I appreciate from a lot of
my classmates as well, yeah.
>> Yeah, I think,
kind of echoing what you're saying, Ruth.
Coming to the GSB and being a woman
of color, being a black woman,
I think is going to be colored by
your experiences prior to that.
>> Yeah.
>> So I went to a predominantly
white undergraduate institution,
have operated in a business world which
isn't as diverse as I would like it to be.
And I think coming to Stanford was
no different than those experiences.
And if anything, I found the community
to be focused on increasing diversity,
equity and inclusion here.
So I'm on the diversity committee, it's
a hugely diverse group of students who
are like we're out here just pushing
even more advancement in terms of what
experiences could be like for
students of color.
For students of historically
underrepresented backgrounds,
for students who are in different minority
groups or whole different identities.
And so to me,
that's kind of part of my way of one,
doing something that I care deeply about,
something that affects me.
It's also related to the social
venture I'm working on.
And so getting to work in a bunch of
different ways on that has been really
powerful.
And working with the administration,
working with other student leaders on
campus has been really fun and rewarding.
I think personally l would echo the black
community at Stanford's super diverse.
And I think the whole
community is diverse.
And I think I already mentioned talk.
But one of the things I loved
about that is it exposes,
even though this person might
appear a certain way and
you might assume different identities or
experiences to them and prescribe that.
I think what is amazing about
Stanford is people will surprise you,
what they've been through,
what they've been, what they've overcome.
And that's true across all backgrounds.
And so I think in many ways,
I feel very much one of so
many different stories in
this larger community.
And I think my experience is
one that people seek out and
I seek out learning about others,
too, so it's pretty good.
>> Yeah, and I would also add that I
think being [COUGH] president of the BBSA
also provides a unique opportunity.
>> Yeah.
>> So whether that's working with
administration on our diversity
initiatives, whether that was someone
tapping me on the shoulder to do some
moderating work yesterday evening.
I think we are in a very visible position,
both pun intended and not.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And that allows us to get involved and
be part of conversations, and
have a seat at the table.
So I think that's important,
too, [COUGH] all right.
So I think speaking of inclusion, this
is I think a really important question.
So someone mentioned they really
want to apply to the MBA program, but
the cost of the program
is a really big hurdle.
Was that also a concern for
either of you, and
does Stanford offer any financial support?
First, before they jump in,
I will say, I encourage
you to go to our financial aid on our
website, there's some information there.
And financial aid, as I'm sure this person
asked, is a very personal situation.
So take what we say with
the right lens for yourself.
But if you do reach out to financial aid,
they will give you more specifics.
But if you guys don't mind
sharing kind of personally for
you, Have you thought about it?
>> Yeah, I think definitely the cost
of attending business school is one of
the hurdles for me to get over mentally.
And not only applying, but once getting
in, if business school was right for me.
It's a super hard decision, and like
Fometa said, it's super personal as well.
What I can say is that since coming to
the GSB, I felt like I'm getting what
I'm paying for, [LAUGH] in many ways and
more than I could have imagined.
And I think starting this venture,
meeting these people,
getting to do these new experiences
that are so much more kind of scope
expanding in terms of how I saw my my life
when I saw what is possible for myself.
What careers existed, so what could
be has been such a valuable part of
the experience that I can't necessarily
put a tangible, this cost that amount.
And therefore it's
a return on my investment.
But I can say that that's
something you're going to have to
decide individually for yourself.
But I have found my time here to be so
valuable already.
And we're only at kind of the beginning
of our spring quarter first year,
at least Ruth and I, and so
happy to talk more about that one on one.
But I think it's something you're going to
have to think deeply about for yourself.
>> Yeah.
>> I think for me too,
I tend to be very risk averse.
So I was thinking about how would I
pay this off and things like that.
But I think, even as a risk averse person,
it was very clear to see that
the ROI here was going to be high.
I think for me, again,
everybody is going to have a different
financially, sort of offer.
If and when you do get into a school based
on different scholarships that the school
offers, and things like that.
But I will say that, even coming here and
just expanding my mind as to what my
financial future can even look like,
based on my different classmates'
experiences and what I've
learned from different professors
has made the cost seem so myopic.
It makes me feel I have thought so
myopically about things whereas I'm like,
actually this is how I should envision
what my financial future should look like.
And this is how small this
cost is compared to that.
So I would even encourage
people not to necessarily,
regardless of what school you're applying,
not to necessarily see this thing as a,
okay, once I graduate school I'm going to
have to be paying off my loans for
the next two years because,
or the next five years or
ten years because,
I'm probably going to be making this much.
Definitely really just understand
that your financial future
really is way more expensive than
probably most people think it is.
And this can be a really small cost if you
really take advantage of really a lot of
opportunities that you have just because
you would have the Stanford brand
on your name, throughout your career,
literally for the rest of your career.
>> Yeah, I will add that for folks who
are thinking about going into nonprofit or
social sector any sort of perhaps,
less lucrative career,
there is a loan forgiveness
program that you should look into.
It's something that was a huge
part of my deciding to come,
knowing that if I wanted to go back and
work at an education nonprofit or
do something in that space,
the cost actually is perhaps prohibitive.
But with loan forgiveness, it became a lot
more reasonable and feasible for me,
at least personally.
>> Yeah.
>> And the school also offers,
to Lisa's point, opportunities for people
who want to go into the social sector
right after school, offers different
sorts of fellowship packages.
>> Yeah.
>> Which again, like Fometa said,
you guys can look online for
it, but yeah, great point.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'm not going to respond to that
question because there's a flurry
of [LAUGH] questions going on.
So I'm going to try to get to all these
questions before we're out of time.
So Lisa, I'm going to direct this to you.
>> Okay.
So, as someone coming
from the social sector,
how have you viewed
the business school experience?
And then for someone who is
interested in the social sector,
what do you say is the value
of business school?
>> Yeah.
So I think coming directly from K12
education, which is extremely progressive,
I was a little taken aback getting
into the the business school realm and
having people say things like
fiduciary responsibility,
and I was like, but the kids!
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I think it has,
what about the kids.
But I think it has been super valuable.
I think there's classes
like financial modeling,
which are just skills that
are important to know.
Accounting was a struggle
at the beginning, but
I think it is important
to build that kind of
business acumen whether you're in
the social sector or the private sector.
I think having that joint degree and
being in Masters in Education is also
a nice pairing personally for me.
In one of my ed classes we were
sitting on the floor, legs crossed,
there was a fire on the projector.
You know what I mean?
So different vibes, but I also think that
vibe can be found in the business school.
And so choosing classes like
social ventures practicum or
philanthropy, there's just a ton of
that sort of energy in the community.
And so
I think although you might come here and
be like everyone's going to be doing
consulting in finance, that's not true,
and in fact so many people talk about
the impact they want to have, and
what that means in whatever
career they're pursuing.
So, yeah.
>> Yeah, yeah.
I definitely agree with that.
I think the other thing too that's really
unique about Stanford that you alluded to
is that there's so
many social related classes.
>> Yes.
>> And then I know one of my good friends
is also a dual in the education program,
and he said that one of those classes on
just the thought process of instituting
education reform, and then coupling that
with policy in the business school was
a way that he even thought about that.
So I'd say get creative too on how you
think about you think about the social
sector, and what skills on both sides.
So the private and the public sector,
what you can do there.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, [COUGH] let's move on.
So I think related on mentality and mind
set, Ruth, I think this is a good one too.
How has the MBA program transformed
your perspective on the issues you
seek to tackle as a leader in your field,
and have your interactions with other MBA
students made you consider collaborating
across fields in the near future?
Yeah.
>> I think for me in terms of
the type of leader that I want to be,
I think coming from a very corporate
role before the MBA made me think
of a leader as kind of, I had this
profile of what a leader looked like.
And you had to say certain things and
you had to act a certain way and
you couldn't be vulnerable in an ABC or
D way, whereas here we're literally
turning the definition of what
a leader is upside down, and
vulnerability is shown
as a sign of strength.
And being able to be honest about
what type of impact you want to have
is not a bad thing, and
it's not just about the bottom line.
I don't even think I've ever heard that
actually used in terms of what people
would consider a successful run of any
sort of business or initiative, and so for
me, knowing what I want to do and knowing
the type of impact that I want to have in
Africa, I think that what I've learned
is that it doesn't have to be one way.
The awesome thing is, for example,
I'm taking a class right now in our design
school, which is an awesome school, by the
way, called design thinking studio, and
I'm seeing how the problems that I want to
solve even don't have to be through tech,
which a lot of people would be
surprised about coming to Stanford.
They probably think that we're super
tech focused and it's only tech,
everything is tech.
But we're really breaking things
down to the bare minimum,
literally using our hands
to build things and
figure out how can we solve a world
problem from so many different ways.
In my class alone I'm working with
a student from the medical school,
somebody from school of education,
somebody from the law school, right.
We're all working on one project together.
And so, I'm learning different
things from how do I solve this
problem through policy, how do I solve
it through journalism, [LAUGH] right?
There's so many different ways to
think about solving problems and so
many different ways of what a leader looks
like that it's helped me to really, again,
break the stereotypes of the path I
thought I had to go, and really understand
that there's so many different innovative
ways to solve different problems and
there's so many ways to do that as me,
not as a profile of somebody
who I think people want to see.
>> Yeah.
I will actually take
this similar question.
But to build on that, I think it's also
important for me, I'm realizing as I'm
heading out, is that leadership
is a journey, not a destination.
And so as we have classes
like leadership perspective,
we have prominent people coming in and
it's just a they give an intro and
then they just stop and
we just get to ask them questions.
And thinking about chairmans of Microsoft-
>> Yeah.
>> And all these other places.
Just the ability to ask questions
like how do you manage your career,
how do you manage a dual career?
It's been amazing.
And so really recognizing that even people
at the top of the mountain are still
working on the next thing for themselves.
>> Yeah.
>> The similar question here is people
of color face unique challenges in
the workforce.
Would you say that GSB gave you the tools
to navigate the unique challenges people
of color face in the modern workplace?
So I'll take that.
I think the answer is yes.
As we mentioned,
through BBSA we get to have some of these
tough conversations, and we get to talk
what is it like being a black woman, and
we get to talk with our male counterparts
about here's some of the unique challenges
that we face, that maybe you guys
aren't really as in tune with.
I think the other thing that
Stanford has taught me is,
I think using my voice and
really feeling comfortable with my truth.
Whether that's through talk,
whether that's through leadership labs,
actually getting the feedback that I
think sometimes as an African American,
getting the feedback that you're
articulate can be a little eh.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
then I actually realized because
one of my classmates was like, no,
you're actually very articulate.
You are above the average.
And I was like, so okay, so for
the first time, actually realized,
okay, this is what this looks like.
So, I think it's really important
to recognize that you're constantly
getting feedback, and through that
feedback there is that self reflection and
recognizing that, okay, here's how I
land on other people or present to other
people, and therefore here's what I
can do as a business leader to either
double down on that or I need to adjust
some of my behavior to seem more warm and
more welcoming or whatever that may be.
So I don't think there's like,
there wasn't a class on how to be a black
leader, but through these experiences and
recognizing and reflecting, I think,
has allowed me to recognize there are
challenges, and having conversations with
classmates, having the courage to speak
up, there is a way to address some things.
Okay, have you recognized that this makes
me feel this way when you say this?
Just really having the courage to speak up
and then kind of stand in my own truth,
I think is important too.
>> Yeah.
There is a class though,
Leadership from Diverse Perspectives.
>> Yes, sorry.
There is that class.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm going to it in the fall, so
I am excited to get into that.
>> Yeah, and
I am building diverse organizations, so
there are some diversity related ones.
Okay, so
this is going to be a rapid one for
you guys.
Let's talk about the academic experience.
What's the curriculum like,
maybe high level case studies
versus experiential versus lecture.
>> They're different.
There's so many different ways to
learn here, which I think are awesome.
So we do have classes that you read a case
each week and you kind of discuss it.
We have classes where each week is,
I'm taking a finance class,
for example, right now and
it's awesome, I love my class.
So essentially it feels like I have two
professors who really it feels like they
write a script the night
before every night and-
>> Yeah, I did that last year.
They're great, yeah.
>> And feed off of each other for,
yeah, finance.
And so they helped me learn finance in
a way that I've never learned it before.
It's not about just equations.
It's about actually
understanding why things happen.
And really,
when I'm paying attention in the class,
I actually can apply it to whatever
I'll be doing in the future.
And then they bring in professionals from
CFOs of Fortune 500 companies who we can
really ask questions, deep and
meaningful and applicable questions too.
So I'll let you guys talk about
your experiences but there's so
many different ways to learn here.
It's pretty awesome.
>> Yeah, there is a core curriculum
around management foundations which,
as the title says,
it's foundational courses in business.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think Ruth alluded to this
earlier, and there's classes that you've
taken the business school,
you can take classes across the street.
One of my favorite classes was across the
street is and other programs at Stanford.
One of my favorite classes was in
the engineering school called,
it's called the lean launch pad.
It's a bunch of folks from all different
schools coming together to explore product
market fit,
it's taught by a bunch of folks in BC.
They bring in mentors from industry, so
that was a great class
that's super experiential.
But I mean even at the business school,
I'm in a class that's all about
social ventures practicum.
I mentioned it earlier, but
we essentially go through what
is needed in a business plan.
And each class is focused
on one piece of that.
They bring in leaders who have
actually gone through that class and
are now leading social ventures.
So someone came in from I think
it was Zimbabwe last week.
Someone was calling in from Pakistan or,
you know what I mean?
It was like a lot of different people
doing different things, which was cool.
And so lots of group projects,
lots of different ways to learn.
And I think that's good since
everyone learns differently.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, cool, I know there are still some
questions on here in career and
professional development.
So I'm just going to go ahead and
take those.
So there's a question on structured
mentorship programs and opportunities.
I'd say it's not structured.
There are some things that we have
with the career management center.
But the career management center,
I also sit on that committee,
has programs available to you if you're
trying to transition from social sector to
consulting, there's a consulting club.
We also have a finance and
investments club.
We have various clubs that take on
essentially the mentorship role.
And then when you start at Stanford
you'll have a fellow, an Arbuckle fellow,
who's a second year who's also
there to help coach you as well, so
that's an opportunity.
Question for the president.
What's next for you after the GSV?
I'll take that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So for
me, I will be moving to Chicago and
working at the Boston Consulting Group.
So I get a nice little break, so
I'll probably do some traveling and
hanging out with folks.
Okay, so last question for everyone.
Did you pay a visit to campus before
applying and if so was the visit worth it?
And then when would you recommend
someone visit and yeah.
>> Ooh.
>> So like I said, my application
process was a little bit different.
I didn't know a ton of
people before applying.
I did visit Stanford but I didn't even
tell administration what my name was.
Because at that point, I didn't feel
like saying who I was, was going to move
the needle and I think that that
played out as I thought it would.
I think visiting the Stanford campus,
while it is important, I do think that
you should have a reason as to why you're
visiting if you really need to be here.
I do think the pictures
do it great justice and
California's what people say it is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So if you are for example,
applying from a different country,
don't feel like you're at a loss
because you can't be physically
on the campus before you apply.
But I will definitely say that if you
apply and you do get in, definitely,
obviously, visit the campus for
admit weekend just get to see how
the vibe is before you actually come.
>> Is there another
time they should visit?
>> So
my application process was very long.
I most recently was in
the Bay Area before school but
also was in New York before that.
And so
I visited campus when I was in New York.
I came for the diverse like Perspectives
Day which I think it's coming up on for
black students,
historically underrepresented students.
And that was actually
a really great event.
I loved meeting other folks who were
applying, hearing different backgrounds.
I also love the alumni who came back and
talked about their experience at the GSP,
met admissions folks.
That was helpful for
me in kind of building this in
as what's Stanford would be.
And then when I lived in the Bay,
it was easy to come down and
check out campus again.
>> I also visited, sorry to interrupt you.
But we had the, when I did get in,
I came for admin weekend which was also
the conference weekend which we're
holding this year on May 10th and 11th.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, it was an amazing experience
for me because I think one of the keynote
speakers that tday was the person who
heads up all of Beyonce's conglomerate.
>> Casual.
[CROSSTALK] [LAUGH]
>> So it was such a great experience to
meet so many amazing professionals,
so many amazing alumni from decades
to recently, so many amazing
prospectives and current students.
So that was a really great weekend for me.
That's where I also met Fometta.
I also met a lot of people
who are my classmates now.
>> Yeah, so quick plug for that.
If you go to BBSA Conference.com,
you can find all the information.
There also will be perspective
student's day portion on the 10th.
So look for
all that information on our website.
And also as mentioned,
Diversity Day will be on the 18th and
we'll also have kind of
a deep dive with professors.
And you'll probably see us and
many more of the current students as well.
All right, so we're out of time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so I would love you
to give you guys ten seconds before
we go to say any final words,
advice for people thinking and
applying this in for an MBA.
>> I would say that Standford is and
can be for you whatever your passions are,
whatever you aspire to,
you can come here and make that reality.
It's a beautiful place where I'd never
felt like I could do whatever I wanted
to until I came to Standford.
And I think it's partially because of
the community, because of the resources.
But I hope to see you here on campus soon.
>> Yeah, I would definitely say Stanford
is a one of a kind place where you get
an experience that can only
be the best thing for you.
And I would definitely say that
in terms of relationships not
just with students but with professors,
with companies in the area.
It's definitely been a great
value add in my life so
I would encourage you guys to apply and
yes, hopefully see you guys next fall.
>> Yeah,
you won't see me because I will be gone.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Fall after that [CROSSTALK]
>> Fall after that yeah, I'm so
tired when I come back to campus
>> [LAUGH]
>> But anyway, great, thank you both, and
thank you guys for joining us today and
your thoughtful questions.
Again, we encourage you to reach out.
Admissions can put you in contact with
anybody in the BBSA if you do have any
more specific questions
that we didn't answer.
And we look forward to seeing you for
the conference or
Diversity Day,
the weekend of the 10th or the 18th.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, guys.
>> Thank you.
[MUSIC]